all right everybody let's go ahead and
start to shut up now
my name's jack griffin and i don't want
to be here
let me catch you up to speed we're not
going to do any biology in here this
won't be one of those things where over
the course of a year
i secretly teach it to you this also
won't be one of those things where
i end up learning more from you than you
do for me
i know more than all of you combined so
that doesn't make any sense
it's the most toxically ambitious group
of students all together in one room
bad news the drama class is unsupervised
and they might be having an orgy
well this is already awesome are you
seriously never going to teach us
biology
if you keep your mouth shut you get an a
if you say anything to anybody you get
an f
this is biology
you're not the boss of me it's literally
my job description that's pretty metal
line up with your books over here we
can't throw out our books what about the
ap tests can we not throw out the books
let's go toss em guys are you gonna be
okay not without my book
how'd you know i didn't hand to god i
did not know oh man i get arrested for
something like that dude
there's so much more coming you should
look scared
what is happening at this school
well this nightmare's almost over oh
what's happening
show's over grab the day by the horns
you